[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhp here and well
welcome back to techtober the event that
we are waiting for just wrapped up which
means i'm not allowed to share that my
daily driver for the past couple days
has been the brand new oneplus 6t so
this phone's had a lot of hype leading
up to it we started seeing those specs
and a little bit of design leaks and
basically got a lot of people waiting
for this phone so the oneplus 6t is in
the purest sense of the word an
incremental update most of it is the
same as the oneplus 6 that we're already
familiar with that i liked a lot and
then you could consider this a bit of a
design refresh a couple months later so
they took the oneplus 6 which is already
a pretty solid and well-liked phone and
they made some upgrades and some tweaks
to things that they felt could be better
and they took it up a notch okay there's
your notch pun for the video so there
are conveniently
six new things with the oneplus 6t so
first of all the new display it's bigger
it's a 6.4 inch display and still your
2340x1080
optic amoled they've been on for a while
and it's still pretty great it's bright
it's colorful and has a built-in
adjustable color profiles obviously i'm
a big phone person and phone screens
keep getting bigger
and i still love it also
slightly smaller chin than the oneplus 6
not drastically smaller but you can see
it when you put them side by side so the
display is definitely an improvement and
that brings us to number two as you can
see
the teardrop notch up here at the top
everything oneplus wanted to do with the
fairly standard notch on the oneplus 6
they are still doing in the smaller
notch on this 6t except for the
notification led so up here is the
front-facing camera the earpiece and the
proximity and ambient light sensors no
fancy face id dot projector or depth
sensors or anything like that but just a
pretty solid basic couple things they
can still do their super fast facial
recognition with the rgb camera that has
its pros and cons and the speaker is
slotted way up here at the top but it
wasn't doing a whole lot anyway so we're
not missing out much by shoving a tiny
speaker up there and for a lot of people
including me this is an improvement
larger screen closer to the bezels and
more room up top for notifications and
info but you can still hide the notch
with software if you want to the only
weird feeling i got about it is like how
curvy it is just i mean that's quite the
curve from left to right if you remember
the essential phone that notch had
probably about the same volume and total
size but it was pretty rectangular on
the sides this one is all slopey and
then it just it just touches the top of
whatever app you're using in the middle
it's interesting but you get used to it
just like any other notch okay number
three is the fingerprint reader
underneath the display something again a
lot of people were looking forward to
happy to see this slowly starting to
become more common in mainstream phones
so that one plus six couple months ago
had the fingerprint reader on the back
that's now gone and it's moved the logo
up a little bit in its place and you can
now unlock your phone by just touching
the glass i've left it enabled the
entire time i've been using it and i'd
say it's it's faster than that first gen
from the vivo phone i first tested a
couple months ago but uh still slower
than the gold standard of like touch id
or a lot of the physical fingerprint
readers it's just somewhere in between
it's not instant but it's just a little
beat of you unlocking your phone it's
it's getting there you can't really just
touch your finger to the screen and then
remove it quickly and get to using the
phone it'll still tell you you're going
too fast but if you leave it there for a
beat you're in pretty quick the
animation is pretty corny i think and
there's two others you can pick from in
the software
but the thing is they all happen at full
brightness that's part of how the tech
of this optical fingerprint reader
underneath the screen works it involves
shining a light on your fingerprint so
even though it's an oled and they can
keep all the pixels black and the clock
is dim to save battery the fingerprint
reader when it reads your finger goes to
max brightness and at night that can be
kind of annoying basically i was hoping
there could be an even more subtle
animation than the three that were
provided also that means that unlocking
the phone at night or when it's dark
specifically is kind of annoying i know
it's definitely nitpicking at this point
but think about it i have both face
unlock and fingerprint unlock enabled at
night when it's dark the face unlock
camera which just uses the rgb camera
doesn't work very well so you have to
use the fingerprint and then when you
use the fingerprint it shines that full
brightness light that kind of bleeds
around your finger into your face which
is kind of annoying just i know that's
again super minor but this is the kind
of stuff you notice when you use a phone
every day so i'll mention it number four
is the new battery so while the phone is
pretty much the same size this is
oneplus biggest improvement on paper
going from a 3300 to a 3700 milliamp
hour battery
that
has been awesome in practice for the
endurance of this phone the six was
already pretty good but i'm now getting
pretty consistently five plus hours of
screen on time one of the days i had
nearly six hours with 10 left
so it might not be a 4 000 milliamp hour
sell like it isn't the biggest number on
paper but this improvement thanks to the
1080p oled and pretty clean software has
this basically my battery champ this
year so far and it still has that
incredibly fast fast charging so that is
impressive then number five
uh it's true the headphone jack
is now gone on the 6t even oneplus
is getting rid of the headphone jack a
moment of silence for its loss so yeah
it's 2018 pretty much only samsung and
lg
are left still riding that headphone
jack train and it's kind of interesting
coming from a company like oneplus who
we know to usually be first to listen to
what users want so when i asked them
what their reasoning was for not having
a headphone jack because i got to ask
them directly they said it's the larger
battery and the fingerprint reader under
the screen both take up so much extra
space in this same size phone that they
felt it made sense to get rid of the
headphone jack so that's their words and
the number six new different thing is
probably the best news this phone starts
at 128 gigs of storage now instead of 64
and for the same exact price as the last
one 549 so you get twice as much storage
for the same starting price and this
whole new design so oneplus is sure
sticking to their guns of competitive
pricing
and then that's it everything else about
the oneplus 6t in the software on the
surface under the hood materials and
build it's all the same as that one plus
six same oxygen os on top of android pie
with the new gestures and all the new
features oneplus has been throwing in
same smoothness and a plus performance
that i was so happy about a couple
months ago that drew me away from the
pixel
same snapdragon 845 and six or eight
gigs of ram so i expect it to continue
to be smooth same colors so it's
launching with this midnight black or
mirror black which means you may still
want to toss on a skin from our sponsor
dbrand this matrix black they have
happens to look pretty damn good and now
you won't see nearly as many
fingerprints so kind of a win-win there
and oneplus still took the shortcuts
they took last year so no wireless
charging for example even though it's a
glass back phone
and it's the same exact camera the
hardware sensor and lens and everything
as the oneplus 6. so you can see photos
from last year's phone they are going to
start to look better with each round of
software updates they're learning a lot
from pixel and iphone's hdr techniques
and building them in here plus a new
night mode is here that does more with
longer exposures and dark scenes but of
course all these changes are also coming
to the exact same oneplus 6 camera since
it's just a software change and they
kept of course one of the most important
things about the six which was a
starting price
easy recommendation this is a great
phone now it's also coming with verizon
compatibility and they're gonna start
working with t-mobile you'll see it in
t-mobile stores i'm assuming so this is
going to be making its first big push
into carriers in the us which is pretty
cool
uh yeah there's a lot going for this
phone it's continued to impress me even
though they got rid of the headphone
jack which is a bummer for a lot of
people but it's been impressive how much
they stick with the fast and smooth
mantra through their phones these have
been consistently the fastest phones i
use for the past couple years which is
great and that's a function of how much
they care about software so i have no
problem recommending oneplus 6t this is
just the oneplus 6 in a prettier higher
tech package
with a bigger battery for the same price
can't really go wrong there so
that's been it what do you think is this
your next phone let me know
thanks for watching
talk to you guys the next one
peace